it's a big day you just moved in with
your boo and you are totally rockin this
living together thing but then comes the
first rent bill and you're stuck
wondering how do we handle this if you
asked your grandparents how they handled
finances back in their day we might be
met with some weird looks after all when
they moved in together they were most
likely already hitched and it was just
assumed that they'd immediately combine
every aspect of their separate lives the
house the Studebaker
Aunt Mildred antique tea set everything
became family property including the
bank accounts in 1960 sixty-five percent
of children grew up in a household where
the mother was a homemaker and the
father was the breadwinner today only 22
percent of children grow up that way
from a rise and women being the
breadwinners to a fall in marriage rates
the relational and economic landscape
has changed dramatically these days 25
percent of parents living with a child
are unmarried and 35 percent of
unmarried parents are cohabitating so
the question is should you consolidate
finances and continue a time-honored
tradition or is maintaining financial
autonomy more important
[Music]
when we asked you on Twitter 79% of you
said you combine all or some of your
finances with your partner and this
tracks with national trends but this is
changing Millennials that live together
are now more likely to keep separate
finances than any other previous
generation and it turns out there are
some pretty compelling advantages to
keeping your finances separate as a
couple Americans with student loan debt
carry an average of over $32,000 and the
typical American is floating over six
grand in credit card debt with numbers
like these it's easy to understand why
one partner might feel guilty or denied
or with something that was their problem
or perhaps you've been in or witnessed a
financially abusive relationship in the
past separate accounts can help protect
you if serious problems arise if you've
ever known somebody that suffered from a
gambling or substance addiction you know
firsthand the financial devastation that
can follow but let's be real
the main reason people keep separate
finances is to maintain their
independence in modern society it's
completely normal to enter your thirties
without ever sharing your finances with
anyone else as your lives begin to merge
it's understandable to feel protective
about your autonomy you've never had
somebody telling you what you can and
can't buy before why start now and if
you don't have to talk about it you
don't have to fight about it right as
attractive as it might be to go lone
wolf there are some good reasons the
majority of couples still combine
finances so let's look at what the
shared approach has going for it when
money is shared you can work efficiently
towards big goals like debt reduction
buying a home is easier when you have
both of your incomes and credit
histories available to work with and if
you plan on spending retirement together
pooling resources makes a lot of sense
think about it is one of you gonna spend
your golden years in a nice condo and
the other in a tool shed probably not
shared finances can also protect you
against unexpected pitfalls like an
injury or layoff and if you enter a
tight season by choice such as taking
time off to start a family or navigate a
career transition anyone will tell you
what a game-changer it is for somebody
to back you up financially
shared cooperation and transparency can
also result in a healthier longer
lasting relationship a 2018 study found
that 20% of relationships that don't
share finances and because of money
problems compared to only 4% of
relationships that do and a series of
five University studies found that
couples who pool all their money are
happier in their relationships and less
likely to break up and don't at us with
the correlation causation argument
the researchers specifically noted that
this wasn't merely a correlation but
that the results demonstrate that method
of account management can influence
relationship quality so it's pretty
clear that how you handle money actually
affects your relationship there are also
hybrid versions of the two like the
proportional earnings approach where
each partner contributes the same
percentage of their income into a joint
account or bill parsing where each
person picks certain bills and expenses
to pay for then uses split wise or Venn
motaz but the large items like rent back
to the big question which is more
important the teamwork or autonomy we
hear a two cents believe you can have
both if you work at it for example we
got hitched young while still in college
truthfully there wasn't much to pull so
we went the traditional path by default
but over the years on flicks arose
because neither of us had much spending
independence we hear this from couples
all the time and it can really start to
build resentment over the years so our
solution was to have it both ways we
combined our finances but we created
individual equally funded envelopes of
fun month to spend or save however we
saw fit so I get guilt free thrift store
runs and I don't need permission to
trick on my mountain bike boom
[Music]
each relationship is unique and there is
ultimately no one-size-fits-all but if
you have decided to share a future
together and have healthy levels of
trust we encourage you to use your
finances as a way to work better as
partners while still protecting
individual freedom and independence and
that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron do you share finances why or why
not
share it with us in the comments
[Music]